[Music]
hello everyone
so in this part of the lecture we'll
start discussing a new topic called
principle strains
and it is an extremely extremely
important topic not only from the point
of view
of examination and for our coursework
but from a professional engineering
perspective also
so what do we mean by principal strains
in order to motivate that discussion
what we'll do is we'll go back
to what we had discussed in the context
of
engineering string all right so quickly
go back to one of the previous slides
you note this very important formula
which
i had highlighted earlier so this was
our compact formula
for our for the engineering string and
we'll start our discussion
in relation to this uh but before
we go about doing that you please note
that this expression
written in terms in in this compact form
the n hat transpose dot epsilon the
strain tensor dotted with the n-hat
this thing is basically the same thing
as if we go go back one slide more
you see uh this thing
is exactly that and that is in index
notation like this ninj
epsilon ij
if we go back
[Music]
and write down this again
[Music]
all right and i also note that this
is exactly equivalent to ni
nj epsilon ij
you please note that and this is very
useful
that when you are writing in the compact
notation
the order in which you are writing the
terms it really matters
okay you're not free to write them in
any order you wish
however when you're writing in index
notation there is no such restriction
you can write them in any order as you
please
okay so this is just like simple
algebraic manipulation
okay now coming back to the physical
discussion why it is so important
uh professional speaking from a real
engineering perspective
uh you see
this is the engineering string okay and
what we had
discussed earlier was that if you sit at
a particular point within the
three-dimensional body and you are asked
to find out the engineering strain and
along a particular direction given by
this unit vector
then you have to use this formula that
is fine
so if you are given a state of strain
and as well as you are given a certain
direction
then you can find out the value of the
engineering stream
however suppose one asks the question
the very important question that
okay they might be sitting at a
particular point there may be
an infinite number of directions around
it now
along which direction should we look
such that the
engineering strain becomes a maximum
i repeat my question we are sitting at a
particular point
and we are free to look at any
particular direction
we set the direction we can find out the
engineering strain
but what about the question that
among all these various directions
denoted by various various values of
this
10 unit vector which is that direction
along which we get the maximum value of
the engineering strain
and what is that value of the maximum
engineering stream so that
question is answered within this purview
of principle strains so that kind of
maximum value is referred to as the
principal strain and the directions
along which
those values are obtained those maximum
values of the principal
values of the strains are obtained they
are referred to as the principal
axis of string so how can we
find out uh how can we go about finding
those directions and those values
that is the purpose here now
there are different ways of proceeding
here but
as in the previous years the method that
i will adopt
is to proceed by taking full help
of the index foundation now as i proceed
with the
with the various steps here you may find
it a little bit difficult to follow
because most of you are not that
familiar with index notation
and please note that
even though from a purely examination
point of view we will not be asking you
questions to derive things like that
based on the index notation because as
third year students
we don't expect you to be experts on
index notation
but people who have some interest to
pursue higher studies
should note down these steps carefully
because it will be useful later on
okay so our question is how can we
maximize this value of this
engineering string
or more importantly how can we find out
along which direction the maximum value
of this engineering strain will be
obtained okay so this is basically an
extremization problem or a maximization
problem
but there is a little bit of a
restriction we have to note this
this is very very important that
restriction is
you are free to find out the direction
with one restriction that that direction
the given by the ni
should be such that it is an unit vector
i repeat
you are free to find out the direction
along with the
engineering strain is is maximized
with the restriction that the direction
you find out the direction vector you
find out
that should be a unit vector because you
know that by definition what
uh the way that we have proceeded and
arrived at this formula here
this n i and n j they are the unit
vectors so that
that fact has to be preserved in our
derivation
so uh very formally speaking
mathematically
this kind of extremization problem is an
is a constrained uh extremization
problem
is a constrained extremization called
let me write that down
[Music]
where the constraint is
[Music]
the constraint being
[Music]
this thing should be equal to zero or
n i
[Music]
in i should be equal to zero
you just you understand that this is
just nothing but the dot product
okay all right now
uh i've written this as uh dot as a
transpose but
uh in the compact notation it doesn't
really matter here so
uh had i written this purely as as
vectors or matrices then this transpose
matters otherwise it really doesn't
matter
okay now how can we set up the problem
okay so we want to maximize the
uh the epsilon e so if we want to
maximum
maximize the epsilon e with respect to
the variation of what
with respect to the variation of this ni
so
let me write that down
now i don't want to use the either the
ni or the nj
i want to keep it generic and i will
write this as nk
all right now
if i uh if i just
said this thing equal to 0 it is going
to be completely wrong
why wrong because here
the constraint
[Music]
is not imposed
which constraint this constraint that it
should be a unit vector that constraint
is not imposed here so i cannot
naively write like this rather what i
have to write
and you'll perhaps remember this from
your first year mathematics
that
i have to write this statement
[Music]
with the
[Music]
extra term here
what have i done here so you see this is
my
extra condition the 1 minus n k k
that is so you see here the way that i
have written it i might as well write
this as
uh s k doesn't matter
i can write it as n p n p n q n q
doesn't matter because this is not a
free index
is a dummy index and i can use any
letter here there is no need to write
this as i it will only create confusion
with this i
so i'm using the nk here okay
now uh
this is this is the original engineering
strain and this is my constraint what is
this
lambda i'm sure many of you will
recognize that this is nothing but the
lagrange multiplier
this kind of a multiplier is used to set
to set up our constraint extremization
problem
so this is the thing that i want to
extremize now it cannot be just this
thing because i have to satisfy this
constraint also
this is
this is like the uh so now the
constraint is included here
and this l this l
is like my objective function and this
is what
i am going to try to extremize
del l del nk that is what should be
equal to 0
this is the proper extremization
statement okay
so let me go to the next next page
and proceed with the actual steps
so i'm just repeating whatever i had
written for the
capital l earlier
this is equal to zero
now
i am going to substitute the expression
for the epsilon i here
which is nothing but n i n j
epsilon i j
and here you note that
i have minus lambda
del del uh
del n n k of
[Music]
basically the nk square
okay now
so this term is very easy you can
understand that
in the next step i am going to write
this as minus 2 lambda n k
no problem there but this one is a
little bit tricky
you take this one by one first of all
you tell me
what will be the derivative so you can
think of it like
three things club together we are going
to take
uh the derivative of this uh using the
chain rule
so first of all you tell me what should
be del epsilon i j del n
k you think for a moment should it not
be equal to zero
the epsilon i j by itself does not
depend on the
unit vector the epsilon i j
sure epsilon e depends on the unit
vector but the epsilon i j
that is just the state of strain at a
particular point
so that has nothing to do with the unit
vector that you are choosing to look at
so the derivative of the epsilon i j
with respect to the
the unit vector that is equal to 0 so
you don't have we can this is like a
constant as far as this partial
derivative is concerned
so you may as well take this out so
let's do that
now uh i want to
to use the chain rule here and write
this uh
like this ni
nj plus epsilon i j
uh or i can just take this thing as
common
ni del nj
del n k you please note that
i am not arbitrarily writing this i am
being very careful while writing these
terms
although it may seem so simple but there
is a little bit of a
of an understanding involved here and
this one i can just write this as minus
twice lambda n k
no problem here okay now we have to use
the proper understanding this is a
crucial step
we have to find out the answer for this
del n i
del n k it seems deceptively simple
it is simple but we have to uh
we have to be little bit careful here so
you see
suppose instead of the ni we had nk
here suppose suppose
we were very fortunate that somehow
there was an nk present
in that case this would have been simply
one
similarly instead of the j here somehow
by some good luck
we had k here then this entire thing
would have been one
unfortunately it is not present but we
have
a little a little implement
or a little equipment in our hand to
convert this
ni to a nk and that is by the use of the
kronecker delta
so what we'll do is we will
i can write this nj here otherwise
that the thing will look cluttered so
this is del nk and this ni
i will write as nk
delta ik
where going by our mathematical
preliminaries
we are using the substitution power of
the chronicle delta you understand that
the resulting entity from this is
nothing but n
i n k delta i k is nothing but n i
itself similar trick i can use for this
next term
again i will write this as nk and adjust
by the substitution power of the
chronicle delta so this is
delta jk close bracket
minus 2 lambda in k
okay now
this thing is no longer difficult
this is simply nj now the partial
derivative of nk
with respect to nk is simply 1 all that
you are left with
is this constant like quantity which is
the delta
[Music]
ik
we write it similarly from the next one
we have this
n one this n one here and
this delta n k delta n k that is one we
are just left with this constant like
thing
which is the delta j k
and minus twice lambda n k
is equal to zero
now you see we are again going to use
the substitution power
of this chronicle delta delta ik
and this time if i multiply this out
what is going to be
substituted you see in this thing there
is no
i there is no k so this one has no power
over this
but here you have you see there is a i
so whatever this
i is it will be substituted by the other
index
k so this one will become epsilon
aj n j
so whatever the index was common with
the chronicle delta that
gets replaced by the other index which
is present in the chronicle delta which
is k here
so that k comes in place of the i here
similarly
here we have delta j k it is the j which
is common this time
so this j in the epsilon i j will be
replaced by the
other index which is present in the
chronic correlator which is k so this j
will become
a k epsilon i
okay and this ni from here
minus twice lambda n k
is equal to zero okay
now you see
this is kj nj this is epsilon ik
ni now
let me use the symmetry property of the
strain tensor so what i'll do is
i'll write this as epsilon jk
nj this one i'll leave as it is
since epsilon aj is equal to epsilon jk
going by the symmetry property okay
now you see
in this first term the j is the repeated
index
okay the j is the repeated index
because this is a repeated index it is
also like the dummy index
so instead of j i can write this as p
so it doesn't really matter because it
is repeated it is not a free index
so i can as well write this as epsilon p
k
np similarly in the second term
i have this i as repeated and because it
is repeated it is a dummy index
so i can replace the i again by p
i am very much free to do so so again
this one will also become
epsilon p k and p so here also i have
epsilon p k
and p here also i have epsilon p k and p
so in the in the next page
i can write this as
epsilon pk um
p k sorry this should be np
[Music]
plus epsilon
p k np
[Music]
minus twice lambda
nk
the reason that we state here is that
replacing
the
dummy indices
j and i by
p
so what we'll have end up with is twice
epsilon
p k np minus twice
lambda and k
is equal to zero
so the twice cancels out and what we are
left with
is epsilon pk np
minus lambda nk
[Music]
now uh what we'll do is we'll once more
use
the uh the power of the chronicle delta
to make this n k to be np
and we'll take the np common that is the
motivation so this is np
minus lambda delta
pk and p and in the next step we'll take
this as
on sorry this should be
a delta
minus lambda delta p
k
np okay now you see
starting from this step whatever we have
proceeded
this is like a full on uh use of the
index notation
and again i repeat that at least for
your examination purposes we are not
going to test you
on these kinds of skills okay this is
only for the
uh or in order to make this
to keep this derivation relatively
shorter we have used this
index notation otherwise you note that
in in full length
if you have to write all the indexes in
full form fully expanded form it would
have taken a lot of space and time
now without going into much further
discussion we can
uh and quickly write this down that this
statement that i have written in the
index notation
this is perfectly equivalent in matrix
representation
like this
you check one by one this epsilon pk
there is nothing stopping me from
writing this
in this matrix form
the corresponding matrix form for the
kronecker delta is the
is nothing but
[Music]
the unitary matrix or the identity
matrix
and this thing
is
multiplied by the
so i don't need this dot in this matrix
representation
i can remove this had i written this in
the compact or vector notation i would
have
needed that so i have this thing
okay so uh
what am i basically doing so suppose you
had to write this down in a computer
uh what would you do so this thing is
perfectly equivalent to this
[Music]
epsilon 1 1
minus lambda
epsilon 1 2 epsilon
1 3 epsilon 1 2
epsilon 2 2 minus lambda
epsilon 2 3 epsilon 1
3 epsilon 2 3
and epsilon 3 3 minus lambda
sorry
okay so uh
whatever we have written here this is
the exact full
uh version of this in in the more
familiar matrix
form that that you know now
uh just for a quick correspondence
this n hat this uh this vector this unit
vector
it has the components of n 1 n 2 and n
3. now
this statement that we are obtaining
this is a system of linear equations
and uh you see that
this is the classic form of the of an
eigenvalue problem
which you are familiar with from your
first year
engineering mathematics days now in
order for this
entire equation to have non-trivial
solution
what you would what you will need you
know the answer
you have to set the determinant of this
matrix
to be equal to zero so
going to the next page
for non-trivial solutions
we must have
epsilon 1 1 minus lambda
epsilon 1 2 epsilon 1 3
epsilon 1 2 epsilon 2 2 minus
lambda epsilon 2 3 epsilon
1 3 epsilon 2 3 and epsilon 3 3 minus
lambda
the determinant of that
please note that i am no longer write
this writing this like a matrix
rather i am taking the determinant of
this that should be equal to 0
so this this equation the equation that
will obtain from
by taking this this determinant
that will give you the equation which
will provide you
with the extreme values of
or the principal the extreme values of
the strains or the principal values of
the strings
and you know what what are we getting
here so this equation will be
a cubic equation in terms of this lambda
okay it will be a cubic equation in
terms of this lambda
and correspondingly we'll end up with
three roots
so those three roots will provide you
with the maximum possible values
of the of the strains uh and they will
be referred to as the principal strains
now going back to our discussion of the
eigenvalues corresponding to each
such root of the lambda you will end up
with a set of
n1 n2 and n3 so suppose your roots
are lambda lambda uh let's say
lambda a lambda b and lambda c then
correspond to lambda
a you will have one set of n1 into n3
corresponding to lambda b you will have
n1 n2 n3 and finally corresponding to
lambda
c you will have the uh the n one and two
and n three okay so
so what we'll we'll put this down in
writing
that
[Music]
the roots of
the above equation
that is the three values
of lambda
will be the extreme values that we are
looking for
will be the extreme values of the
engineering stream
[Music]
and
[Music]
so these please note that these extreme
values are the lambdas
so these are like the eigenvalues
these are the eigenvalues and
corresponding
to each
such extreme value
we can find
[Music]
a set of
n1
n2 i think better written as
a vector
a set of n1
n2 and n3
it is extremely important to note that
uh please do not have this misconception
that's what i'm
trying to emphasize here it's not that
you are getting three values of lambda
and corresponding to those three values
these are the n one and two and three no
you get three values corresponding to
each lambda you will get
three values of three these three values
n1 n2 n3
so first answer so well that's what i
meant
so suppose your first root is lambda a
corresponding to that lambda a you will
get one one set of this n one into n
three
you change the value of lambda b go back
to the eigenvalue problem
and try to find out the eigenvectors so
these are the eigenvectors themselves
you'll get another set of n1 and 2n3 you
go to the lambda c
the third root you'll get another set of
n1n2 and n3
this is extremely extremely important so
these are the
will be referred to as eigenvectors
okay 3 such sets
you will obtain three such sets
corresponding to each lambda
corresponding to each
lambda value okay
so i repeat that each of these lambdas
have the eigenvalues
and each such set of n1 and 2m3 are the
eigenvectors
is the eigenvector all right so
uh so going back to our original
question
so these eigen values will give you the
different
possible extreme values of the
principal strains or the maximum
engineering strains
and the corresponding eigenvectors uh so
each of these n1 into n3
so they will be providing you with the
directions you note that these n1
n2 n3 are also the direction cosines of
the
of the unit vector that you are
interested in and because we have
we have we have worked for this
derivation uh we have to put in some we
had to put in some work
in order to ensure that that the
constraint
1 minus nk was
ensured so this they will be
set up in such a fashion that they will
be
uh unit vectors so n 1 square plus n 2
square plus n 3 square
should be equal to 1 all right
thank you very much so in the next part
of the lecture we're going
we'll be going on to the last topic of
the kinematics chapter
thank you very much